T
50-MILE LONG VEHICLE CONVOY
HEADED TO KYIV.
NATIONAL SECURITY CORRESPONDENT
JENNIFER GRIFFIN IS AT THE
PENTAGON TONIGHT WITH THE
LATEST.
GOOD EVENING, JENNIFER.
>> GOOD EVENING, BRET.
AS PUTIN'S FORCES FACE SETBACKS
MANY U.S. OFFICIALS WORRY HE MAY
BE PUSHED TO USE MORE LETHAL
WEAPONS THAT COULD CAUSE LARGE
SCALE CIVILIAN CASUALTIES LIKE
THESE THEY'RE MOW BAKER WEAPONS
VACUUM BOMBS KNOWN AS THE FATHER
OF ALL BOMBS GENERATE HIGH
TEMPERATURES THAT CAN START
FIRES AND BURN EVERYONE AND
EVERYTHING WITHIN ITS BLAST
RADIUS.
THEY WERE A GRIZZLY SYMBOL OF
PUTIN'S DESIRE TO WIPE UKRAINE
OFF THE MAP.
HIS ARMY IS TARGETING CULTURAL
SITES AND IN A SICK TWIST AFTER
THE RUSSIAN LEADER SPOKE OF
DENAZIFYING UKRAINE, THE RUSSIAN
MILITARY BOMBED THE HOLOCAUST
MEMORIAL IN KYIV, A REMINDER
THAT NOTHING IS OFF LIMITS.
HERE IS THE MOMENT THAT
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY, WHO IS
JEWISH, WAS TOLD BY HIS CHIEF OF
STAFF THE MEMORIAL, WAS BOMBED.
>> MR. PRESIDENT, I WOULD LIKE
CONTINUE TO FORM THAT BOMBING --
>> BOMBING.
>> THE MEMORIAL?
>> YES.
WILL [INAUDIBLE]
>> U.S. DEFENSE OFFICIALS ARE
WATCHING THE SLOW PROGRESS OF
THE 40-MILE CONVOY COMING TO
KYIV.
REASONS IT MAY BE STALLED, THE
RUSSIANS STILL DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
GAS AND HAVE RUN OUT OF FOOD.
REPORTS SUGGESTS SOME RUSSIAN
SOLDIERS ARE PUNCHING HOLES IN
THEIR OWN FUEL TANKS TO STOP
THEIR VEHICLES FROM MOVING
FORWARD.
U.S. OFFICIALS SAY THEY HAVE NO
TREASON DOUBT THOSE REPORTS.
SOME RUSSIAN SOLDIERS HAVE
SURRENDERED EVEN WITHOUT A
FIGHT.
MANY ARE CONSCRIPT, NOT TOLD WHY
THEY WERE THERE.
THEN THERE IS THE HIGH TECH HELP
SENT FROM OUTSIDE UKRAINE, ELON
MUSK DELIVERED